the world is dying there is nothing to
go back to if our people are to survive
we wasn't like a whole media my name is
Gail Murr and I am a luke development
artist and fur groomer on Warcraft hair
crafts is a pipeline tool that works
with 3d softwares and with it were able
to emit fur to generate for a hundreds
of thousands of hair strands on the orcs
for the hair styles and for the
customers hair craft was created
especially for Warcraft we knew early on
that we were going to need a lot of very
detailed hairstyles and customers for
the orcs with hair crafts you can
generate braids you can generate costume
fur you can generate eyebrows but you
can also generate body fur and we had a
lot of body fur on the Ox the amount of
detail in the hairstyles is phenomenal
the amount of detail on the skin the
costume for the jewelry it's pretty
incredible as you guys are going to see
hair crafts allowed me to manscape
you